philosophers of all sorts have long
debated whether happiness
whether happiness can in some way be
driven whether it can be driven by money
and i've included three quotes here that
i at least found entertaining not
necessarily that i agree with them and
it'll get our brains in the right frame
of mind and then we can start to think
about this philosophical question a
little bit algebraically and at least
there won't be any right answers here
but it'll get our it'll get our minds
going a little bit so this first quote
here money if it does not bring you
happiness will at least help you be
miserable in comfort helen gurley brown
and i guess you know you can't really
disagree with that statement
money is not the most important thing in
the world love is
fortunately i love money and that's
that's not me saying that that's jackie
mason and this third statement it is
pretty hard to tell what does bring
happiness poverty and wealth have both
failed and that's by ken hubbard and i
hope they've found happiness in some
other way outside of poverty and wealth
now with that out of the way let's try
to express this whole thing
algebraically so let's say if we wanted
to see how money might give us happiness
and obviously we're over simplifying
here so i'm going to make a couple of
statements and they're going to think
about how the money might lead to
happiness in each of these statements so
in the first statement maybe happiness
maybe happiness is just equal to money
is just equal to money
the second statement
second statement may be happiness
maybe happiness is equal to the square
root
the square root of the amount of money
you have and then the third statement
maybe
maybe happiness
maybe happiness is equal to money
squared
is equal to
money squared so let's think about this
a little bit before we even decide which
of these best are best to represent what
our philosophies actually are what i
want you to think about is if i have ten
dollars
if i have ten dollars so let me just
send a neutral color so if money
if money
is equal to
if money is equal and let's not do 10
let's say money is equal to 100
if money is equal to 100
i want you to think about how much how
much happiness will we have in each of
these scenarios let's do each of them so
scenario one
give you a few seconds although you
probably don't need it how much
happiness would you have if you have a
hundred dollars
well this is pretty straightforward
happiness is equal to the money in this
situation
so happiness
happiness
is equal to
100.
now let's think about this situation
scenario two
if you if happiness is equal to square
root of money and if money is equal to a
hundred dollars
how much happiness will you have i'll
give you a second to think about that
well in this situation your happiness
happiness
is going to be equal to the square root
of money but we know that the money is
equal to 100 so it's going to be equal
to square root of 100 and the square
root of 100 is equal to 10. so in
scenario 2 you have 10 i guess you could
call them happiness points now let's
think about scenario 3 how much
happiness will you have in this
situation if you have a hundred dollars
well your happiness
your happiness everywhere you see the
word money you just substitute it with
the amount of money you have your
happiness is going to be your money
which in this case is 100 is going to be
100 squared or 100 times 100 which is
equal to
which is equal to
10
000.
now what i want you to think about and
you could try this out with different
numbers and see how the value of
happiness changes based on what value
for money you pick but i'm going to ask
you a question it has no right answer
but i'm just curious which of these do
you think best approximates your
philosophy of how money might impact
happiness
so once again absolutely no right answer
here but we could think a little bit
about what each of these statements are
saying here we're saying happiness is
directly equal to money here saying as
it's equal to the square root of money
so if you have so as money grows
happiness will not grow quite as fast
although it will grow and here it's
equal to money squared so as money grows
a larger and larger happiness will grow
even faster it's equal to money squared
so my best guess and once again no right
answer in my own opinion has changed
throughout my life is it's probably
closest to something like this your
happiness can in some way obviously if
you're able to support yourself and your
family that might lead to less stress
and more happiness but the more money
you have as your money grows your
happiness might not grow as fast as that
but once again no right answer it's
completely up to your opinion